au grand débat de ce club d'aujourd'hui
évidemment consacré à la réforme des
retraites nouvelle journée de
mobilisation samedi et les syndicats
durcissent le tombes naçant de mettre la
France à l'arrêt Aurélien Romano
Paris réussi pour les syndicats deux
journées d'ampleur en une semaine la
journée de mardi avait marqué une légère
baisse celle de samedi est revenue à des
niveaux importants une mobilisation plus
familiale comme ici à Marseille de
nombreux enfants étaient présents dans
des cortèges très compacts ici à Nantes
au total près d'un million de
manifestants d'après la police 2,5
millions d'après la CGT face à l'absence
de réponse du gouvernement les syndicats
annoncent vouloir durcir le mouvement
l'intersyndical appelle à mettre la
France à l'arrêt le 7 mars date situé
juste après la fin des vacances d'hiver
pour toutes les zones une position forte
défendue par tous les syndicats même la
CFDT d'habitude plus réformiste et moins
jusqu'au-boutiste on appelle avec la
France à l'arrêt ça s'appelle des choses
qui existent par exemple en Espagne par
exemple des commerçants qui baissent
leur série en ce moment qui baisse leur
rideau au moins symboliquement pendant
une heure ou deux aujourd'hui on a fait
la démonstration la plus grande
mobilisation je le répète personne on
pas de son pas d'image du gouvernement
une position qui étonne le gouvernement
sauf pour autant inquiéter pour le
moment nous nous avons fait preuve
d'ouverture de concession nous avons
écouté nous avons entendu nous avons
amélioré notre copine ou laissons les
parlementaires faire des propositions où
on travaillait par exemple sur l'index
senior et de l'autre on nous dit soit
vous cédez sur votre réforme soit c'est
le blocage du pays je le dis avec
beaucoup de gravité cette logique là
n'est pas acceptable afin de garder la
pression les syndicats maintiennent un
rendez-vous hebdomadaire prochaine
journée d'action ce jeudi 16 février
et la culture du conflit est désormais
inéluctable
mais je suis pas faut peut-être attendre
qu'il se durcisse d'ailleurs
non parce qu'il y a normalement
médiatique qui m'étonne moi je trouve
que ça ça fait oublie plutôt et que la
réponse justement à la journée d'action
de blocage c'est une réponse justement
parce que les syndicats ont peur que ça
soit ça y est ça se dit seul veut
complètement la journée de samedi est un
échec il faut le dire il faut arrêter de
que les médias marchent avec une espèce
de bourdon médiatique où non je suis
désolé normalement il devait y avoir le
double de personnes puisque justement
c'était ouvert aux familles c'était
ouvert maintenant c'est pas le cas ça a
pas été le cas
oui mais alors attendez les vacances
scolaires et depuis quand les vacances
scolaires empêchent un mouvement social
ça c'est pareil c'est cette France
confortable complètement contradictoire
paradoxal si vous êtes contre une moi
mais vous partez pas en vacances d'abord
si vous partez en vacances c'est vous
avez vous êtes pas affecté par par ce
type de de mesure il y a quelque chose
de sincèrement quand les gens nous
regardent à l'étranger mais ils sont
ils sont ahuri quoi c'est ahurissant
cette histoire donc qu'est-ce qui se
passe on va voir je pense que le la loi
va être votée l'Assemblée nationale elle
va partir au Sénat c'est un mouvement
qui à mon avis est un mouvement qui est
qui ne va qui va s'évanouir au fur et à
mesure il y aura une journée de blocage
et alors ça sert à quoi de fermer son
rideau une heure comme ça c'est pour
faire plaisir aux syndicats si vous êtes
contre la loi vous fermez votre rideau
tout le temps et puis vous vous en payez
les conséquences bon il faut il faut
quand même qu'on se voit un peu adulte
dans ce pays non
d'accord on va tout droit vers un
système de retraite par capitalisation
tout droit avec ça on est en train de
casser le système je suis souvent
d'accord avec qui mais j'ai un petit
désaccord quand même sur la journée de
samedi il faut voir que les
manifestations le week-end ça jamais
beaucoup mobilisé c'est vraiment un
problème c'est vraiment un problème pour
les syndicats en réalité et c'était
risqué et malgré tout le fait qu'en plus
en pleine vacances vous organisez cette
manifestation et que elle fasse mieux
que mardi c'est déjà plutôt un succès
pour les syndicats parce qu'il faut pas
voir forcément des manifestations qui
sont je dirais à manifestants permanent
même si vous prenez la réforme de 2010
par exemple vous voyez que ça tourne que
sont pas les mêmes manifestants et que
donc ce faisant et bien de nouvelles
manifestations un autre jour servent à
mobiliser de nouvelles populations et
donc ce faisant à étendre le mouvement
c'était l'objectif des syndicats c'est
un objectif risqué et en ça ils ont
plutôt bien réussi leur coup les
manifestations avec beaucoup de
personnes qui manifestent ça sert à quoi
en réalité politiquement ça sert pas à
grand chose c'est jamais ça qui a fait
reculer un gouvernement ça permet de
d'assurer l'opinion que et bien la
bataille peut être remportée et essayer
de construire une forme d'adhésion de
l'opinion et ça les syndicats ont déjà
réussi quand vous prenez les enquêtes
non seulement les Français sont très
majoritairement à tort ou à raison
opposés à cette réforme mais ils sont
même et c'est plus importants ils sont
aujourd'hui en capacité d'accepter
visiblement regarder le dernier sondage
au doxa un durcissement des instruments
qui vont être des instruments de blocage
il y a quelque chose qui s'est passé
important ces tous les jours c'est la
position de Laurent Berger quand Laurent
Berger contre la tradition un peu de la
CFDT dit ok on va pouvoir aller vers des
blocages ça signifie que celui qui a
réellement les clés dans ce mouvement là
aujourd'hui étant est en train de bouger
national
qui aujourd'hui
donc en règle générale qu'est-ce qui se
passe dans les mouvements qui
réussissent à bloquer les réformes vous
avez toujours quatre étapes blocages
soutien de l'opinion majorité qui se
fissure et une fois que la majorité
c'est fissurée difficulté à faire passer
la réforme on verra bien ce qu'il en est
parce qu'en effet là où je rejoins Yves
c'est que le gouvernement a tous les
outils procédural aujourd'hui pour faire
passer cette réforme donc elle mesure il
juge que le coût pour sa majorité sera
trop important ça va être ça le la
prochaine question on va revenir sur ce
qui se passe à l'Assemblée dans quelques
instants avec Alex vous vouliez dire un
mot avec le gouvernement à tous les
outils procédure pour faire passer cette
réforme au Parlement mais quand même on
peut se demander si au fil des semaines
il y a toujours des millions de Français
dans la rue que le mouvement se durcycle
pays commence à être bloqué est-ce que
le gouvernement pourra véritablement
utiliser le 49-3 c'est à dire avec trois
quarts des Français qui sont contre le
report de l'âge c'est ces millions de
manifestants une majorité très très
fissurée sur ce texte démocratiquement
ce sera très difficile pour le
gouvernement de dire bon bah tout le
monde est contre nous mais on fait quand
même le 49.3
est-ce que c'est pas de loto
persuasion ça non mais il faut qu'on
arrête aussi de est-ce que les gens ils
peuvent être qu'est-ce qu'ils peuvent
travailler plus longtemps personne moi
je ne connais personne qui veut
travailler plus longtemps il y a plein
de gens qui vous disent si on travaille
pas plus longtemps et ben on n'aura pas
de retraite donc vous avez aussi plein
de gens qui se disent ben il faut quand
même que ça passe et donc le fait que
vous soyez opposé ne veut pas dire que
vous êtes conteste que vous êtes dans la
contestation
sincèrement vous savez quoi
il y a 30 millions plus de 30 millions
d'actifs ce qui est un ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'à la fois trois
quarts des Français dans les sondages
d'opinion qui sont opposés à cette
réforme mais il y a aussi une majorité
de Français qui est favorable à une
réforme des retraites pas forcément
celle-là mais qui est conscient qu'il
faut changer le système pour le
rééquilibrer financièrement avec avec
d'autres solutions regardez la réforme
dit à 4 ans elle a répondu à 4h n'était
pas du tout cette réforme là bah vous
aviez une majorité de gens qui étaient
contre voilà alors que Monsieur berger
là qui qui ne fait pas pour moi
l'opinion en France dieu merci et j'en
ai assez qu'on ah oui ils sont tellement
raisonnables la CFDT mais ils sont pas
plus raisonnables que les autres
non non mais c'est vrai il y a une
espèce de musique qui est assez récente
dans ce pays et
vous regardez il était pour la réforme
de 2017 et les Français n'étaient pas
d'accord avec lui
je préfère taper sur l'herbe mais ce
matin c'est le Robert berger
il faut il faut il faut savoir c'est
vrai nos distances avec tout ça c'est
vrai mais c'est son âge d'opinion
souvent je suis désolé je suis pas anti
sondage mais souvent ne veulent pas dire
grand chose tout de même si vous voulez
il y a plusieurs éléments qui en effet
peuvent conduire je dirais à rendre à
ses probable un blocage regardez
2019-2020 je suis d'accord c'est pas du
tout la même réforme mais l'opinion
c'est cristallisé depuis à towar raison
contre l'idée d'une réforme des
retraites mais vous avez à l'époque la
plus longue grève de la Cinquième
République 50 jours dans les transports
avec aujourd'hui on l'a vu lors des
dernières grèves des capacités de
blocage qui permettent les greffes
tournantes tout bêtement parce que et
bien vous savez que si vous bloquez dans
quelques secteurs vous paralysez le
système et donc ce faisant entre
guillemets les syndicats en ont les
moyens si vous prenez les grèves
notamment de 95 vous voyez qu'en règle
générale Quentin blocage commence le
premier qu'on va chercher en disant toi
tu as tort de nous bloquer c'est pas le
syndicat c'est le gouvernement or là
quand vous prenez le sondage au doxa qui
est paru il y a quelques jours 64% des
Français si jamais il y avait blocage on
tiendrait comptable le gouvernement et
pas les syndicats donc aujourd'hui les
syndicats ont les moyens l'opportunité
est probablement au vu du timing de la
réforme plutôt l'intérêt et l'urgence de
bloquer pour tenter de gagner cette
bataille est-ce que ça peut mener une
victoire politique pour eux avoir ça
c'est pas si évident mais en revanche le
blocage en tant qu'outil politique en
tant qu'outil de
bataille dans cette réforme les
syndicats vont probablement y venir et
entre guillemets pour eux cette bonne
guerre
ce sont les éligibles au régime spéciaux
les régimes spéciaux en l'occurrence ne
sont pas touchés sauf avec la cause du
grand-père ce qui rentre dans ces
services ces services publics en
l'occurrence
à la RATP ils ont gagné 100 euros
d'augmentation net par mois ils sont pas
du tout disposés à bloquer à bloquer le
réseau urbain absolument pas pareil à la
SNCF à la SNCF ils ont eu leur heure
difficile avec une réforme qui a eu lieu
en 2018 si ma mémoire est bonne donc ils
sont pas du tout disposés non plus à
faire une un blocage comme ça voilà
qu'est-ce qu'il a c'est pas les
commerçants qui vont bloquer la France
bien sûr que non donc alors qu'est-ce
qui va bloquer la France pardon
il suffit d'enlever d'envoyer les forces
de l'ordre et vous les non mais c'est ce
qui s'est passé je suis désolé c'est ce
qui s'est passé en 2010 vous avez à la
fois d'autres revendications on a vu
notamment à la SNCF etc qui peuvent
faire contamination dans ces milieux là
même si je rejoins Yves sur le constat
de je dirais à relative privilège de ces
secteurs et de l'autre côté vous avez un
taux de pénétration syndicale qui fait
que si demain la CGT la CFDT et
l'ensemble des syndicats disent on
bloque il est assez probable que
justement via grève tournante et
quelques secteurs clés ça bloque on va
voir ce qui se passe à l'Assemblée
puisque évidemment l'examen du texte va
reprendre cet après-midi Alex on en est
où sur le fonds
adopté l'article premier qui supprime
certains régimes spéciaux de retraite et
vendredi dernier ils ont attaqué
l'article 2 qui prévoit un index sur
l'emploi des seniors c'est à dire que
les entreprises de moins de 50 salariés
devront publier un indicateur sur leur
taux d'emploi de seniors et si elle ne
le font pas et bien elle s'exposeront à
une amende une amende pouvant aller
jusqu'à 1% de la masse salariale alors
les oppositions le RN la gauche sont
contre cette index des seniors car ils
estiment que c'est une mesure est
coûtait le député socialiste Jérôme
Guedj
l'emploi des seniors c'est le point noir
du marché du travail et nous aurions pu
de manière consensuelle nous dire tous
ensemble que la vraie réforme des
retraites était de mettre le paquet sur
la résorption de ce chômage élevé chez
les seniors et pour le moment le
position a échoué à supprimer cette
index sur l'emploi des seniors mais le
débat sur ce sujet va continuer
aujourd'hui et Alex vendredi les débats
ont été perturbés par un nouvel incident
de sciences oui en cause le tweet du
député insoumi thomasport où on le voit
le pied sur un ballon à l'effigie
d'Olivier du socle le ministre du
Travail un tweet qui a été condamné par
toute la classe politique sauf les
insoumis et qui a fait monter la
pression vendredi dans l'hémicycle le
ministre Olivier du soft s'en est pris
aux insoumis écoutez
[Applaudissements]
dans la violence vous voulez continuer
dans la stigmatisation vous aussi vous
voulez poser avec ma tête coupée et face
aux demandes de retrait de son tweet le
député insoumi Thomas porte à persister
et signé
retirez mon tweet le jour où vous
retirez cette réforme qui va sacrifier
des milliers de gens voilà
[Applaudissements]
et en conséquence Thomas porte a été
suspendu de l'Assemblée nationale
pendant 15 jours une sanction que la
gauche juge disproportionnée et après
cette première semaine de débat hésiter
la deuxième s'annonce tout aussi tendue
ah oui c'est le sentiment du ministre du
Travail Olivier du socle il était hier
chez nos confrères de France 3 on
l'écoute vous vous attendez à un climat
tendu oui je pense que ça sera du même
acabit que la semaine dernière vous avez
montré aussi sans ton image ça tombe de
scènes avec une volonté d'obstruction je
disais tout à l'heure mais j'aimerais
qu'on puisse parler du fond du côté de
la gauche on estime qu'avec ces milliers
d'amendements il en reste encore 15000 à
examiner et bien on est justement sur le
fond ce n'est pas de l'obstruction
écoutez l'écologie c'est Sandrine
Rousseau
il y a pas tellement d'amendements
ubuesque non
mais ils sont pas
si on prend mais si on prend par exemple
le désamendement que moi j'ai déposé
avec le groupe écologiste on a une
proposition par exemple de taxer les
super dividendes et en fait on a une
proposition de taxation à 10% puis à 9
puis à 8 puis à 7 puis à 6 puis à 5
voilà mais en fait la fin le fond de
cette affaire c'est de taxer les
dividendes les super dividendes ce qui
n'est toujours pas fait en France donc
en fait c'est que du fond de cette
affaire c'est que du fond mais en face
la majorité estime qu'il faut aller
quand même un petit peu plus vite dans
le débat pour arriver à l'article 7
l'article qui est reporte l'âge légal de
départ à 64 ans écoutez ce que proposait
hier Aurore berger la patronne des
députés Renaissance
France insoumise dès lundi matin retire
tous ces amendements dont ils savent
très bien qu'on aura 1000 temps les
discuter et qu'ils ne seront pas adoptés
et on passe dès lundi quand on reprend à
l'Assemblée nationale sur le vote sur
l'article 7 avoir maintenant si la
France insoumise va adopter la stratégie
proposée par Robert berger
ouais finalement
c'est la maîtrise du temps des débats et
du
un grand parti alors c'est évidemment
l'obstruction et ce que vient nous
définir Sandrine Rousseau c'est ce qu'on
appelle les amendements cocotiers ça a
été inventé par Jacques Toubon la loi
Savary vous mettez plein de rendements
avec des chiffres différents pour faire
perdre du temps c'est l'objectif de
l’obstruction la plupart des réformes du
règlement à l'Assemblée au Sénat depuis
les années 80 ont pour but de juguler
l'obstruction le gouvernement se prendre
comme un manche pour juguler cette
obstruction en 2019 comme aujourd'hui
mais qu'importe malgré tout c'est
quelque chose qui rentre dans le jeu
parlementaire et je crois qu'il faut pas
porter forcément de jugement parce que
c'est la stratégie parlementaire et dans
un régime de la cinquième ultra
rationalisée où le gouvernement à toutes
les capacités d'action faire de
l'obstruction pour l'opposition c'est
souvent la seule perspective de pouvoir
potentiellement l'emporter là c'est
l'obstruction tout de même extrêmement
tendu extrêmement caricatural
souvenez-vous 2006 Jean-Louis Debré
c'est 138 amendements sur la table etc à
l'époque on est dans une mise en scène
de l'obstruction qui et bien malgré tout
reste bon enfant là c'est pas bon enfant
et ça c'est une vraie rupture ensuite
pour répondre à votre question oui
à malgré tout une stratégie et cette
stratégie est pas tout à fait idiote
parce qu'en réalité ils peuvent les
retirer les amendements pour l'instant
ils attendent que la majorité craque
s'épuise et si jamais elle devait
s'épuiser si jamais demain vous deviez
avoir potentiellement des majorités
contre tel ou tel article des majorités
pour telle ou tel amendement voir une
majorité contre le texte là vous verrez
vite les amendements s'envoler le débat
avancé et le gouvernement être battu
c'est plutôt de bonne guerre c'est
plutôt intelligent après en effet dans
du point de vue du débat public c'est
parfois un peu caricatural mais c'est
pas fait pour débattre du fond c'est
fait pour gagner une bataille
parlementaire politique
ment dans ce débat j'en sais rien parce
que je pense que son discours est quand
même assez pollué par un tas de
l'histoire du ballon avec la tête du
soft
pour le moment il le joue bien parce que
ils font justement cette obstruction
je trouve que ça manque quand même de
colonne vertébrale de discours il y a
pas un discours de fond qui soit
qui imprime je dirais qui c'est plutôt
de l'agitation quoi et je trouve pas
qu'il y a un discours
un vrai discours de gauche construit
personne ne le porte ce discours là vous
l'entendez pas
et Benjamin me disait que la France
insoumise mise sur un craquage de la
majorité si jamais hier était optimiste
un vice-président que vous prenez sens
lui pour pour lui il manquera aucune
voix à l'appel de son groupe c'est vrai
que on s'en passe cette majorité craquée
les voix sont ultra minoritaires qu'on a
entendu de barbara Pompili de
du député Vignal finalement il y a pas
de mouvement de fond si vous voulez mais
même d'ailleurs chez les républicains
chez les républicains dont on disait que
peut-être plus d'un tiers d'entre eux
serait opposés à la loi c'est pas
quelque chose qu'on entend on entend
monsieur Pradier qui est tout seul dans
son dans son discours à répéter sans
arrêt la même chose bon je suis pas sûr
enfin je trouve pas si vous voulez qu'on
ait pris une grande hauteur même dans
l'opposition contre cette loi je trouve
que c'est un débat qui finalement est
assez pauvre
oui il y a plusieurs il y a plusieurs
façons de faire craquer une majorité
entre guillemets la première façon c'est
de jouer sur les fractures au sein de
cette majorité et là la montée de
mayonnaise syndicale etc vise à faire
que les députés de la majorité se sont
pris entre deux possibilités soit en cas
de dissolution aux prochaines élections
à être battues soit et bien tenter de
continuer à se battre sur cette réforme
en espérant qu'on l'oublie et là ça peut
créer des positions très très
différentes avec des fractures c'est ce
qu'on connaît à certains moments lorsque
les réformes sociales à chopent il y a
une deuxième façon de faire craquer la
majorité qui au vu du timing ici et plus
probable c'est qu'en réalité les députés
de la majorité votent avec leurs pieds
si jamais vous avez des minorités qui
deviennent majoritaires à un instant T
en séance parce que les députés de la
majorité en ont marre n'en peuvent plus
de ces débats qui ne mènent nulle part
préfèrent aller un circonscription parce
qu'on leur a dit il y aura peut-être une
dissolution demain et donc ce faisant
entre guillemets va faire campagne ce
qui est un peu l'injonction
contradictoire des menaces de
dissolution faut voir que l'hémicycle on
le voit peut-être pas très très quand on
voit évidemment ces images là mais on le
voit malgré tout relativement audible
etc mais quand vous êtes à l'intérieur
c'est une cocotte-minute c'est
extrêmement pénible ça fait extrêmement
mal à la tête combien de temps vous
résistez pendant des jours et des jours
au sein de cette émission sans vous dire
je vais retrouver ma circonscription si
jamais trop font ça si jamais la
majorité a de plus en plus de mal à
mobiliser et elle a l'air de même pour
ceux qui sont favorables à la réforme à
ce moment-là ça devient très compliqué
pour le gouvernement c'est aussi ça qui
est visé aujourd'hui par la fi et puis
alors donc les bas sur l'article 7 le
report de l'âge à 64 ans en débat qui
est assez clivant ou peut-être que oui
la majorité avec les républicains peut
l'emporter mais après il peut y avoir
des amendements de compromis
c'est-à-dire des mesures sociales qui
pourraient être proposées et rajouter à
ce texte et qui pourrait au final
embêter le gouvernement car elle
représente et bien quelques milliards
d'euros de milliards d'euros de dépenses
en plus et certains députés les
républicains qui entendent quand même un
certain mécontentement dans leur
circonscriptions ils pourraient être
amené à apporter une majorité
d'opposition sur ces mesures de
compromis et le gouvernement pourrait
être embêté avec un texte modifié et qui
coûterait au final beaucoup plus cher
que les économies
je pense que justement ça serait la
contre-pied de leur réforme et ils ont
en mémoire les épisodes de 2007 sur les
régimes spéciaux justement ça c'est
vraiment à mon avis la limite qui ne
veulent pas franchir il y avait deux
stratégies au sein de la nuque on peut
dire qu'il y avait une stratégie la fi
c'est celle qui l'a emporté le mur
d'amendement et on fait craquer la
majorité et il y avait une stratégie
qu'on pourrait qualifier de stratégie
communiste qui était plutôt poussée par
le groupe communiste qui visait à dire
on va pas déposer tant d'amendements que
ça mais ces amendements on va faire
qu'il puisse emporter des majorités pour
grosso modo défiguré le texte et une
fois que le texte aura été défiguré
plutôt à notre profit dans un sens plus
social avec le soutien de député LR etc
le gouvernement aura du mal à l'assumer
il sera obligé de le purger à plus de 49
alinéa 3 le coût politique pour lui va
être extrêmement violent le stratégie là
est fin à emporter il est pas certain
que la stratégie communiste n'aurait pas
été une meilleure stratégie au vu du
contexte la question de de la semaine
c'est est-ce que le fameux article 7 qui
reporte l'âge légal de départ sera
examinée est-ce que tout le monde a
intérêt est-ce qu'il soit vraiment
examiné et mis au vote il moi je pense
que oui les la majorité a intéresse
qu'il soit discuté puisque c'est le
c'est vraiment le poisson tral du du du
débat et comme ça ils pourront pas
on pourra pas leur opposer le fait que
le je dirais le cœur de la réforme n'est
pas été discuté démocratiquement à
l'Assemblée nationale donc ils ont tout
intérêt est-ce que ça soit discuté assez
évident parce qu'en réalité c'est en
effet sur cet article là qui peut y
avoir le plus de crispations au sein de
LR et de la majorité et ou peut-être une
majorité peut être difficile à trouver
regardez les l'article liminaire
regardez les motion référendaire etc
tout ça n'est pas passé si loin que ça à
la motion référendaire tu es loin de
passer mais il faut voir qu'il y a pas
une majoritaire absolue pour se
prononcer contre donc malgré tout il y a
des frictions il y a des fragilités
et donc ce faisant cet article 7 malgré
tout il est quand même dangereux de la
majorité là ils sont tous là alors il
faut arriver à les mobiliser il faut
arriver à ce qu'ils veulent tous dans le
même sens pour le gouvernement à ce
stade là c'est pas si évident qu'est-ce
qui se passe Benjamin puisque là on a
dit c'est la dernière semaine d'examen
du texte pour que ce soit clair pour
tout le monde qu'est-ce qui se passe
vendredi à minuit alors il y a deux
choix le gouvernement n'est pas
contraint comme on le dit de faire
passer le texte au Sénat s'il veut
laisser durer les débats il y a rien qui
constitutionnellement n'en n'empêche en
revanche s'il veut faire passer le bébé
au Sénat il peut le faire passer la
question en Suisse c'est celui de la
cautionnalité de la loi on a quand même
quelques offres de presse qui montre que
Laurent Fabius n'est pas
particulièrement heureux de
l'utilisation du 47-1 qui serait quand
même plutôt enclin à attendre en vote
pour valider la procédure donc la seule
façon pour qu'on soit clair vendredi
potentiellement au sein
dans lequel c'est l'une des rares
exceptions cautionnelles donc si jamais
on a modifié à la marge l'article 1
l'article 2 et bien ils arrivent
modifier à au Sénat et le reste arrive
en l'état si tu n'as pas et encore été
voté vive le gouvernement a intérêt à ce
que ça arrive au Sénat ou les débats
s'annoncent peut-être plus
facile la procédure est telle que ça
normalement au Sénat il devrait pas
rencontrer de de position moi je pense
que techniquement je vois pas ce qui
pourrait gripper la machine je vois pas
du tout je pense pas que la majorité
soit divisée je pense que la majorité
est tout à fait
c'est simple personne n'a intérêt à la
dissolution
donc ils ont pas du tout intérêt à ce
que il y a une crise passion du débat je
pense que la majorité ça va être le vote
de la peur
oui alors la dissolution est très
improbable le l'exécutif en serait
probablement la première victime quand
on voit les élections partielles ensuite
cette réforme elle va essentiellement se
faire en commission mixte
paritairement là où elle sera totalement
adoptée et totalement potentiellement
modifié en accord entre le Sénat
l'Assemblée nationale il faut voir qu'en
commission mixte paritaire LR a plus de
parlementaires que la majorité et que
donc cette réforme lorsqu'elle ira au
bout au vote finale sera en grande
partie au terme et aux conditions de LR
et de LR du Sénat et
[Musique]
ensuite